In this playlist, we've been
constructing a monetary or
banking system that reasonably--
in the simplified
form, approximates the
system we're in.
So we said, OK, we need
a banking system.
And we went the fractional
reserve route.
We said, we'll take deposits,
but we realize that most of
the deposits just sit there.
People really don't use them so
let's re-lend out some of--
90% or 50% of the deposit--
some amount.
So we have to keep some fraction
aside as reserves and
that way we can use that money
to lend more, but in the
process, we create a multiplier
effect and create money.
So that's what we described; a
fractional reserve system.
And when we talk about reserves,
what we originally
talked about reserves
was gold.
It was gold based.
We started off with
the farmers.
They had their gold.
Gold was the unit of exchange
from primitive times.
It was the first agreed
upon medium, and
people kept with that.
And then we eventually showed
that in a fractional reserve
system when you have this
multiplier effect and you
become kind of an advanced
Western industrial economy, to
some degree the gold might just
sit in the central bank
vaults and just kind of
provide this kind of
confidence in the system, but
really, it does nothing there.
It just provides a confidence.
And at some point we show--
I think it was in the last
video-- that you can actually
just go off the gold standard
and you could go onto a
non-hard currency-- or
not-backed by gold.
And the point of that is really
to get to where we are
today and to show that
it isn't crazy.
There's a lot of-- I guess you
could call them conspiracy
theorists who think that there
was kind of a negative intent
behind going off of the gold
standard and that it was
somehow stealing money.
And you know what?
I'm not 100% sure that they're
not wrong, but I'm just saying
since then, it's not like we've
had wealth destruction
and that we've turned
into some type of
post-apocalyptic society.
Economic growth has been pretty
fast. There's been
innovation.
Productivity has increased.
So at least as far as I can
tell, it seems like you can
have a reasonable economic
system that's not backed by
gold, that's actually backed
by the actual wealth, where
the wealth is the productive
capacity of a country.
So, not backed by gold.
And that's where we got
to in the last video.
I think I struck a nerve a
little bit because the gold
really isn't fundamentally doing
something and it really
is just a medium of exchange.
And some people said, how
can you say that?
Gold is definitely
worth something.
There's no reality
in which gold
cannot be worth something.
Gold controls other assets.
So it it's good to, I think,
one, think about what other
routes we could've taken
down this banking
system evolution tree.
And then also think about-- I
guess, revisit the notion of
gold itself.
So if we just think about--
let's revisit gold first
because I think that's what a
lot of people care about.
So there's two things
that I was drawing
a difference between.
And it's a philosophical
difference, but I think it's
an important one.
It really helps, I guess,
get a handle on
things in the world.
So there's money and then
there's wealth-- and this is
tricky because at the end, these
are just definitions and
definitions take on different
meanings as time goes on.
I looked up wealth in Wikipedia
and it gave the Adam
Smith definition-- from The
Wealth of Nations-- and he
talks about wealth as the land
and-- I think it was the land
and labor that produce
utility for humans or
something of that sort.
So essentially his definition
is, wealth would be things
like land, it would be food, it
would be shelter, it'd be
transportation, it would be,
I don't know, it would be
entertainment to some
degree, right?
That provides some utility.
It makes us happier.
Or it could be things that help
produce these things like
factories or-- who knows what
else-- computers, things that
help us produce all of these
things more efficiently.
And if you stay in that mindset,
money is not wealth.
Money is just a medium of
exchange for wealth.
You could say money has value.
The value of money really is the
oil or the lubrication of
the economy.
Without any form of money, you
would have to be bartering.
If I was a a home builder and I
wanted to get bread, I would
have to exchange a house for, I
don't know, 10,000 loaves of
bread, which just is
not practical.
Instead, I can exchange it for
money and then later exchange
that money for bread.
And within this money medium of
exchange context, there's
different types of
money, right?
There's paper money.
There's hard currency,
et cetera.
And gold would fall under
this context.
And then there's a fundamental
question: Is gold
fundamentally, intrinsically,
worth more than paper money?
And I guess it goes to
just, what do you
think is going to happen?
I mean, the benefit or the
negative of gold or a lot of
hard currencies is
that it's scarce.
And by it being scarce, it's
not like you can just print
this stuff and there's
always going to be a
set supply of it.
And so if someone took a
negative spin on it, scarcity
would mean less flexible.
Or if you took a positive spin
on it, you could say it can't
be manipulated.
And both of these are probably
true to some degree, right?
But that's what it is.
It's just a scarce
unit of exchange.
And so I'm not saying that gold
will one day lose its
ability to control some of these
things or be exchanged
for some of these things.
I'm just saying that money or
the unit of exchange is
fundamentally different than
these things that actually
provide utility.
I mean, gold does have
some applications.
Maybe you say it provides
entertainment
in the form of jewelry.
Maybe does provide
some utility.
It can be used as fillings
or in some industrial or
electronic applications,
but primarily
it's a unit of exchange.
And as a unit of exchange, it
helps just facilitate the
transactions amongst wealth and
helps the economy allocate
resources efficiently.
Now, paper money is
not scarce, right?
It's controllable.
And so you could take a negative
or positive spin on
that, right?
You could say it's flexible.
That would be the positive
spin on it.
Or you could say it could
be manipulated.
And there are times in history
where many governments, just
kind of push for populist
agendas or to somehow try to
defer problems maybe until the
next guy shows up, they did
manipulate currencies.
And that did lead to
hyperinflation and eventually
the paper money becomes
worthless, but then there's
other examples where the paper
money, for the most part,
really does retain its value.
So that's another thing
to think about.
And so just going back to the
question of whether gold will
or will not lose its value,
that's just really-- I mean,
what is it going to lose its
value relative to and what
would be the catalyst for it?
So a lot of people right now,
they'll say, the dollar--
there's going to be
hyperinflation because the Fed
is being so proactive, so
I'm going to buy gold.
And they might be right.
I'm not sure about that.
If I knew about that
I would go and
speculate on gold myself.
But the main thing in any type
of investment is to realize
that you're making a bet on
what human beings will do,
what the Federal government
will do.
And just as an example, in real
terms, if you adjust it
for today's dollars, gold
in 1980 was-- this is in
inflation adjusted dollars-- I
think it was on the order of
$2,400, right?
So even today, even with all
of this talk-- I guess it's
2009 now-- even with all this
talk about hyperinflation, the
Fed being overly aggressive and
us pumping up the money
supply and the Fed's balance
sheet expanding-- even today,
gold-- in today's terms-- this
is $2,400 in today's terms. I
think it's at $840
or something.
And back in 1980, a very
reasonable person could have
said, my God, we have
hyperinflation, we just got
through these oil shocks,
inflation is going through the
roof-- inflation was already
much more rampant than it has
been in recent memory-- and
you're like, boy, the dollar's
going to be worthless
before we know it.
I'm just going to buy gold,
although-- what
should gold be worth?
Should it be worth $24,000?
Should it be worth $2 million?
Who knows?
Does gold just go to infinity
in terms of dollars or does
the dollar just go to zero?
So someone could've made a very
reasonable argument back
then that they should get out
of their bank accounts and
convert it all to gold and they
wouldn't have been able
to predict that Paul Volcker
would show up in the early
'80s and increase interest
rates despite all of the
political pressure to maybe
do the opposite and he got
inflation under control.
And then by-- what was it?
By the late '90s, in today's
terms, gold was-- I think in
the $200 range or it might've
been even lower.
We'll say approximately $200.
And even if that person said,
even in the late '90s, I'm
going to hold to my bet and keep
holding gold, it would've
taken-- if they'd had it all the
way to today, they still
would have been better off in
1980 keeping their money in a
bank account that gets more
interest than inflation.
So if you just got 3% or 4% on
your bank account starting in
1980, you still would have been
better off than holding
gold-- even though there was a
very credible argument for
inflation at that time.
So it's just a very, very
hard thing to predict.
And with any of these things
where you're really just
betting on the medium of
exchange, it's very
hard to price it.
It's very hard to say
what that unit of
exchange really is.
So now gold has ran up from
the late '90s to $840.
It's based on a lot of people
thinking that the dollar's
going to lose its value,
et cetera.
It's completely possible.
We might have an irresponsible
government.
Inflation looks like it's under
control right now, but
who knows what happens
in a year or two?
Maybe all this liquidity starts
to get a multiplier
effect and the dollar
gets debased and
gold jumps up to $8,000.
Then those people just have made
a great bet, but maybe
inflation isn't the problem.
Maybe it's deflation and
maybe people don't lose
faith in the currency.
Maybe a Paul Volcker-like
character shows up and tackles
inflation and then gold
goes back to $200.
But the bottom line here is
that it's really hard to
predict because it's actually
not generating utility itself,
it's a measure of utility.
But anyway, I don't want to
fixate on that too much, but
it's an interesting
discussion.
But anyway, just going back to
the original thing, there's
other ways that we could have
gone down the evolutionary
path of banking systems. I just
wanted to go over the
path that we've gone.
Instead of a fractional reserve,
you could have a full
reserve system.
That's-- instead of me taking a
deposit and saying that you
can demand the deposit at any
given point, but still lending
90% of it out-- that's what I do
in the fractional reserve--
I would tell you, 90%
of your money, you
can't take it out tomorrow.
It's going to be locked
in for six months.
It'd be like a CD and the money
that you want to have
tomorrow, I'm just going to put
it aside, you're not going
to get any interest on it, and
you might have to even pay me
a little bit of money to keep
it safe and to be able to
access it from an ATM.
That's completely fine.
Someone could argue that
this is less flexible.
That would be the negative
spin on it.
But then the positive spin on it
is maybe it's less subject
to manipulation.
Or maybe there will be a few
less booms and busts, right?
Maybe these bubbles
won't form.
I'm not so sure about that,
but I think it's
a reasonable argument.
And then even within full
reserve, we could have gone
gold or not gold.
And once again, that would
have just been a question
about how much flexibility you
have. The most restrictive
system would be a full reserve
system based on some type of
hard currency that can't be
printed or can't be controlled
by humans to some degree.
Or you could have something that
is printed and then to
some degree this could be
manipulated a little bit.
And just like on the fractional
reserve--
fractional reserve backed by
gold-- little less flexible,
but maybe that's good.
Little less game-able as well.
Anyway, I just wanted to give
you this kind of overview of
everything.
Because I think I maybe struck
some nerves in the last time.
I didn't want to in any way
insult gold and I don't think
that tomorrow gold will
be worthless.
I just wanted to make it
very clear that from a
philosophical point of view,
there's a difference between
gold and the things that it can
be exchanged for, just as
there is a difference between
money or-- any kind of money--
paper money and the things that
it can be exchanged for.
And in general, I think gold
does have a special place
relative to any other
hard currencies.
Relative to diamonds, or
nanotubes, or anything else--
and that's just because it
has a history, right?
From the beginning of recorded
history, people used gold as a
medium of exchange, so it's
almost ingrained in our
cultural DNA and that's what
gives it its robustness as a
unit of exchange, but other
than that, it's really no
different than diamonds,
or carbon
nanotubes, or moon rocks.
Anyway, I've used
up all my time.
I'll see you in the
next video.